what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
audrey peters video um called i'm a
feminist until i'm not because of these
things before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification
bell i've also just dropped a sweatshirt
line so if you want to support my
channel please consider
you know getting one be helpful
um
okay before i start i wanted to say that
i do like
audrey
oh sorry but i just disagree with her on
this so let's go
don't get me wrong i'm a feminist until
i'm not because some of these things
first up on the list um my feminism
immediately exits my body when i
approach a bar club and especially when
i enter i will do whatever it takes
literally whatever it takes um
to get into that club or bar and to
never have to pay for a thing i'm doing
in the entirety of the time i am in the
clever bar i think this is perfectly
reasonable
this is the issue with this we as women
we want to have our cake and we want to
eat it too so we want traditional men
that are going to do all the traditional
things but we're not traditional women
anymore
we're not
and i think if you're going to be asking
for a traditional man you have to
present yourself as a traditional woman
this is the tax that men should pay for
existing in society next up is an
obvious one um
so second thing i don't think it's funny
to
like joke about
men existing as a problem
like
i i
think that women would have a
would throw a fit honestly if men were
calling us [ __ ] if they were calling
us [ __ ]
in in public on tick tock
on social media like we don't even like
being told we have to lose weight
can you imagine saying like these
[ __ ] shouldn't exist we would have to
have a fit
and
yet
we're gonna joke about that i just i
don't find it funny i have brothers i
don't find it funny
the moment a check gets near me and
there's a man in the vicinity as far as
i'm concerned there is still a wage gap
and chivalry is not completely dead so
again all of a sudden i don't know what
feminism means if i there isn't a wage
gap
there isn't not when you take into
account the numbers of hours worked the
industries that women pick
like it's been debunked so many times
but like i swear girls like don't want
to hear it we don't see a door and
there's a man with me um i act like i
don't know what it is in that moment
i've never touched a door or seen one in
my life and last but not least if i
happen to hang out with a guy's girl i
don't support you i know your intentions
and you're not cooler than me because
you drink beer i could come up with a
million of these don't get me wrong
i don't know what a guy's girl is
is it like a pick me is that it
i feel like the pygmies don't drink beer
i don't know
but
okay
i really like her i like her channel i
follow her but i just i'm not with this
whole
let's let's demand traditional men but
we're not going to be traditional women
i i'm not with it i don't think it's
interesting or cute
so let me know in the comments what you
think do you think i'm wrong do you
think i'm right don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos and i will
talk to you guys next time